nicaragua's president says he will not
consider stepping down to restore peace
to his country hundreds of people
protested in the streets yesterday in a
new demonstration against the government
of Danielle ortega police and
paramilitary groups are accused of
killing more than 300 people since April
and while Bojorquez is in the capital
city of Managua Nicaragua watching the
uprising and well good morning good
morning the latest protests paralyzed
the streets of central Managua for
several hours yesterday but there were
also demonstrations in favor of
President Daniel Ortega and while no one
here wants to see a civil war the air is
thick with tension about what could
happen next
for bigges critics this was not just
another protest it was another day in
the fight against a regime they call
oppressive this started in many ways as
a student movement if you look around
here you can see it still resembles very
much that a lot of the people here are
young and they say this is about their
future protesters like this young man
hide behind masks because Ortega has
governed Nicaragua for twenty-two of the
last 39 years increasingly amassing more
wealth and power critics say in an
interview Monday Ortega explained why he
and his wife the Vice President won't
step down says we were elected by the
voters elections begin in 2021 and then
we'll have to see who will be voted in
his supporters say he's earned their
vote and denounced the protesters as
violent they are harming an entire
community they've destroyed a city
they've destroyed a country this woman
says but while not a civil war this
woman says there are already political
prisoners she claims her husband a
former military officer has been jailed
for almost a month after refusing to
join a paramilitary group fighting the
demonstrators I can't rest because I
know the regime is capable of whatever
in order to convict an innocent man she
said so I'm fearful I'm scared but she
also later added Nicaragua has
Saida to defend itself that may make
this conflict prolonged yes hoping to
avoid more bloodshed nicaragua's Roman
Catholic Bishops met yesterday to
discuss restarting talks between both
sides which had previously fallen apart
the turmoil in this country will reach
100 days on Thursday when more protests
are expected Gayle all right Manuel
Bojorquez reporting from Nicaragua thank
you